you'll rarely meet successful people who
are not insightful
uh i believe that insight is the
smallest unit of truth that is
actionable
uh
and and therefore people who operate in
the currency of insights
tend to be generally more successful at
least in business
[Music]
a lot of founders who pitch to me are
usually well prepared and make a
presentation and come to me and so i
tell them that hey i don't understand
english very well
can you explain this to me in hindi
what does it do
founders who really get what they're
doing can switch language without a
problem
because they really get it
and language doesn't change anything for
them
many people who have just prepared their
presentation and not really understand
this very clearly they struggle with the
language change and their pitch goes for
a toss
that's so so hold on one way to i just
want to add p back on this because like
one way that you can do this without
switching languages is switch level of
the conversation
so often people prepare at one level and
it's like oh can you go deeper or can
you go higher level and keep that in
context which is sort of like the same
idea yeah yeah
and
i've seen that people who are really
good you change language you change
medium you tell them you i don't want to
read your presentation they'll still be
okay
uh some people will tell them i'm not
gonna look at your ppt and they'll be
like how do i explain this to you uh
the other framework that has worked for
me is uh
i tell them i don't understand anything
what you're saying
imagine i'm a user of this product
and i have to tell a friend
over dinner
to try this
what do i say only rule i cannot use any
jargon because i don't speak to my
friends in jargon
so tell me what do i say
and i tell them to take 10 minutes break
before telling me the answer
most
i would say 90 percent of founders fail
at this
because
they can't really distill it to that
simple transmissible
message
from a friend to friend
if you cannot distill your idea to a
transmissible
conversation at dinner
it's not going to spread
and things that don't spread will have a
huge cack
because nobody really understands what
the hell are you doing
that's one framework that has worked the
other one is uh
uh
asking them what is the real motivation
people will use it a lot of times
the real motivation is different than
what people say is the real motivation
for example buying expensive headphones
they are not really to make you hear
better you want to signal to the world
that you are affluent and you have good
status and good taste
most founders cannot distill that that
is the real reason people will buy it
they'll keep going to the functional
utility and not the emotional benefit
of the product
and that's another framework i've seen
that good founders always know
functional and the emotional benefit of
their product or service
what else i have seen uh
market sizing
most founders cannot imagine how will
they start from here and go on to build
a
very large thing from here they get
stuck in
uh
this is what i do but they can't imagine
how will this become a large company
ever they just don't think they don't
even think they don't even they cancel
their own idea and i've seen the
opposite type which is i call it the
swiss knife problem
they believe that they have to build a
swiss knife when the consumer only is
looking for a knife
because they love building so a lot of
them are usually with engineering
background they love the builds they
write so much software
that consumers are confused when they
talk to them because uh they don't have
a foot in the door strategy that okay
let me sell a knife and then eventually
become a first knife in their life
they start with the idea of swiss knife
and you're like hold on
i can't even process what you guys are
doing and swiss knife becomes cool
nobody uses it
like everybody seems to have a swiss
knife but never being used
so i think that's another pattern i've
seen
i've never really thought about this
from a
human framework problem but uh
another thing is that why would somebody
pay for this and
it's surprising how most people do not
understand that
nobody's gonna pay for that like like
just that
basic test
nobody's gonna pay for that like uh
like will your dad pay for this will
your mom pay for this will your cfo pay
for this will your kid pay for this
like
they are just off on that uh
the last one is uh
insights
do they have
an insight that
is not obvious
but when you see them talk about you
like uh-huh that makes sense
uh and and uh
you'll rarely meet successful people who
are not insightful
uh i believe that insight is the
smallest unit of truth that is
actionable
uh
and and therefore people who operate in
the currency of insights
tend to be generally more successful at
least in business
can you go deeper on that the smallest
unit of insight that's actionable
a smaller unit of truth that is actually
truth
truth that's actually yeah go deeper on
that for a second
so
if you
go to ancient hindu mythology and you
study the sanskrit
scripts and sensor was a very condensed
language right because it was invented
before paper was invented so
knowledge was transmitted from human to
human through memory so they had to
distill
the wisdom
in the smallest unit possible that could
be memorized and transmitted from human
to human
and in the earliest scriptures were also
tight like you you'll read in sanskrit
yoga line and like in one line they'll
condense like really a lot of wisdom in
it
so i think the concept of
boiling something to the core units of
it then you cannot divide it further
becomes a powerful unit that is also the
building blocks or what we call as first
principles
that can help build businesses right and
i think a lot of times
uh
it's a painful process seeking truth is
painful
shen you've been doing this for a while
like how many more blogs will it take to
get close to the truth you will probably
not find it but the joy of seeking truth
for the sake of it
uh
is not natural and therefore a lot of
people do not appreciate it enough but
insights become this nice building block
through which you can create
great businesses unlock great success
uh because that is something that is not
commonly available
everybody seems to be seeing some
pattern but you see something else
for example i had this
view that oh india cares about status so
much more than the western society let
me do an thought experiment i reached
out to my friend who is to be a buyer of
a top retail chain in india i asked her
to check can you check if the gross
margin on all products sold for living
room
is lot more than the gross margin of all
products sold for the bedroom
nobody had ever analyzed data like that
in retail ever
because it's like kitchen and sofa and
furniture and all of that nobody thought
living room and bedroom has two separate
concepts
but i said can you please make somebody
crunch it and turns out the gross margin
was 3x more
the reason is in a society we care more
about showing to others so all the
products which are showing demonstrating
status were put in the living room our
bedrooms are terrible in india because
nobody comes to them
and therefore it was not surprising that
bed sheets were not bought expensive in
india and bathroom products do not sell
a lot we don't have a lot of bathtubs in
india
because
it's not about me
it's about showing social status to
others who come to my living room
and therefore you apply that insight now
and i told this inside to a a home
renovation company i told them don't
keep saying home renovation launch a
product line which is living room
renovation
and today 70 80 percent of that revenue
for them is living room renovation
because that's the inside
and that's the motivation button that
you can press in people
so i think
distilling things to
these points and that's when you realize
that oh western society is exactly
different people will buy so many of
these products for their bathrooms and
bath bombs and candles and all of this
stuff
none of these exist in india but in fact
the bathrooms are even smaller
well i think in the in the western world
it's about treating yourself it's about
you're worth it it's about
we still have a status thing
individualism versus individualism
versus collectivism which is how asian
societies are
and therefore you don't deserve things
to be special but you have to show it
and therefore weddings
are really big and very high gross
margin it's for others
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you